okay next lauren bobert story lauren
bobert has been reported to the fbi
uh for allegedly inciting violence by
saying that we need to terminate the
presidency
of joe biden now she doesn't say
impeachment she doesn't say 25th
amendment she says terminate the
presidency of joe biden and now
she has been reported to the fbi
newsweek lauren bobert reported to fbi
after terminate this presidency tweet
lauren bobert has been reported by
several users the house republican from
colorado on sunday appeared to mock
president joe biden after he mistakenly
said presidency instead of pregnancy
when discussing abortion rights being
restricted in the u.s following the
revoking of roe v wade
um
in response to her tweet actually let's
look at the tweet first quote we need to
terminate this presidency end quote
repeat the line
unfortunately
you can't just terminate things you
don't want lauren we've got to see this
out through its full term and this is
really getting into fascistic rhetoric
particularly
in light of a former world leader just
being assassinated it doesn't feel like
an overreaction to say that lauren
beaubert should be investigated over
this and the term is stochastic
terrorism i've told you guys about this
before stochastic terrorism is when you
have a large enough audience that if you
feed an idea
to enough people it starts to become
statistically likely that someone will
act on it so for example when you are i
don't know tucker carlson
and if you were if he were and he's not
doing this exactly but if he were to
every night say
we need someone to deal with joe biden
in a permanent way
okay he's not saying go out and kill joe
biden but with a large enough audience
it would start to become predictable
that someone's going to try to act on
what tucker carlson is saying in exactly
the violent way that he is implying it
this is not hypothetical
we have seen these incidents happen in
the past there was there's this guy
glenn beck i believe he still is on
the blaze maybe is i think glenn beck is
associated with the blaze a right wing
outlet
where when he had a program on again i'm
thinking back i think it was on fox
although was it cnn now i don't even
remember he became obsessed with
hammering on the tides foundation the
tides foundation it's an enemy it's evil
it's all this different stuff and
california highway patrol ended up
actually pulling a guy over who was on
his way to do violence to the tides
foundation because he heard glenn beck
talk about it now could you hold glenn
beck legally liable for that no now if
it was significantly more direct then
maybe you could but in that way you're
not going to hold glenn beck legally
liable but stochastic terrorism is a
cultural phenomenon
if you um
continue
hammering on whoever
then these things are going to happen a
more recent example during the pandemic
donald trump talking about the china
virus
china did it never should have happened
there have to be consequences they must
be punished and on and on and on
and it leads to
just on the street hate crimes against
people believed to be of uh asian and
pacific islander origin and we saw it in
the united states random asian women
punched knocked down knocked out in some
cases some of these things caught on
video is trump legally liable no did he
say go out and punch random asian people
on the street no
but from our cultural understanding we
would start to realize oh it's going to
become likely that that will happen when
you have a large enough platform and you
start putting these messages into
people's minds and that's exactly what
lauren bobert is doing here with we must
terminate uh this presidency stochastic
terrorism it's the term we've seen it
before
it's real
and unfortunately
there i mean there's two sides to this
one
a lot of these things
don't rise to the level of criminality
and i'm not saying that they should they
they just often don't and number two
there is so much of this that law
enforcement can't even keep up federal
law enforcement investigative agencies
secret service keeping up threats
it's overwhelming the degree to which
this type of thing is out there and if
you listen again listen to the voicemail
that i posted to my instagram and to my
twitter this morning
you will see
that these folks are everywhere and
we've got to be very very cautious and
concerned about them and lauren bobert
is just making the problem worse